this goes back to the number one thing I
think about every day of my life if
you're authentic to yourself not chasing
every [__] thing and you can [__]
do this then you can [__] win the
problem is most people can't tune out
the noise cuz they [__] want to hear
the accolades the reason people struggle
with people's judgment on the negative
is because they get high on the positive
the reason my [__] that's so real you
get a thousand love comments the two
haters you look at I
something me
some real [__] you guys know this I post
and I get a lot of love because of the
way I rolled and when I tell you those
9,000 goat emojis that come in comments
I can't hear them I don't think I'm
special yeah for real talk I'm aware I
got stuff we all got stuff but because I
don't let them gas me they can't tear me